ναιμε μπορεί ο παροχαίας να είναι σε μια χώρα αλλάδε σημαίνει ότι είναι εκεί που
απαπό καύπο τέλα υπάρχουν ταηλεκτροντικά δα εδομένα τα οποία πρέπει να εξεταστούν και να δούμε
υπάρχειουν πάρω πολλές υπηρεσίες ανονημίας α αρουπμος έχουμε πει και λοιπά που μπορούν ν εξασφαλίσουν
διαφορα ηλεκτρονικά τα ρχει δρομίον αυτά όλα αυτά και ναπροσπαθίσουν να επιδήχουν το σκοπόν τους
είναι όλα αυτά που αντιμετοπίζουμε συνεχώς και προσπαθούμε να είματε και εμείς ένα μοντέρνογραφείο θέλεται
ναακολουθούμε την τάση του εγκλήματος και να μπορέσουμε ντεπξέρθουμε δυστυχώς για αυτή τη υπόθεση δεν
υπάρχουν μέχρι στιγμής παρόνο που εχουσταλί υπεθυμίσεις από τις ρο τισικές αρχές αναμένουμε να δούμε
τη εξέλιξα μιικ αταλάβατα στην ποεγούμε να ροηση την προσπάθησα αλλά το διακόψαε ότιαφρά τα
πηλιτικώ μήνημα στον πρόεδρο θα το πάρω διαφορετικά χωρίς ονόματα ο πρόεδρος χρηστοδουλίδης ήταν το
μοναδικό άτομο απειλήθηκε στα όσα χρόνια βρίσκες τα το λεκτωμανικό έγκλημα ύ υπήρξαν και άλλοι
πολιτική που δέχθηκα να πλητικά μήνηματα χωρίς να πούμε ονόματα ή χρονική περί και να
σας ευκολίμε χωρίς και παρει να να απ κάτι δεν έχω υποψημου κάτι το στην
κεκριμένων για τα τελυταία χρόνια ατο παλεθον υπήρξαν κάποιες περιπρασης τελευταίω να δύο χρόνια δεν
υπήρχα δεν περιλήθευν κάτι στη αντίληψη αλλά τα προηγούμενα χρόνια υπιεξαθα παλαιότερα να ταξι ε
διχρατται τώρα να βούμε κάποια διπερισότερα ελ λεπτομέρες και λοιπάν πάμε λίγο πίσω στο σκοτενόδια
δείκτυο μιλήσατα για τιμοκαταλόγους που σίγουρα σοκάρει αυτό δηλαδή να μπορείς να πεις μέσα και
να να μπορείς να βρειστι μές για να κάνει σκαγώσι σε κάποιον άνθρωπο η τιμοκατάλογη
που έχετε μπροστάς εσίς σθα γραφείο πουμε